Todd Blackledge ESPN college football
analyst former NFL and college
quarterback led Penn State to the
national title in 1982
he's calling Syracuse and Clemson
that'll be Saturday at noon on ABC and
also a sign a new contract contract
extension with the mothership Todd good
morning how are you I'm doing great dan
how are you it's good back on your show
again this Clemson Syracuse game got a
whole lot more interesting because of
what was going on with the
quarterbacking situation tell me what we
need like behind the scenes here Dabo
Sweeney Kelly Bryant who had an
unbelievable track record there of what
sixteen and two and now he's out in
Trevor Lawrence's is the star the
freshman I think what you've got here is
a situation where you've got a very
capable guy in Kelly Bryant and you're
gonna probably be able to win every game
on your schedule and every game you
would play in the ACC I don't know if
he's the kind of quarterback from a
passing standpoint that's good enough to
beat and Alabama and Ohio State a
Georgia in the college football playoff
I think Da'Ville Sweeney is counting on
the fact that Trevor Lawrence who is a
much better looking passer even though
he's just a true freshman gives them a
better chance to win that kind of a game
I think he made the decision when he did
to give Kelly Bryant that option with
the new redshirt rule having played four
games to make a decision what he wanted
to do I'm sure he was hoping that Kelly
Bryant would say hey I want to stay here
and you're probably gonna need me before
this year's out to win the whole thing
and I'm part of this team and that's
what I want to do but he made a business
decision what he thought was in his best
interest to say okay that's it for me at
Clemson I'm gonna I'm gonna go try to
play next year somewhere else well this
is the new wave here that you can it's
not what have you done for me lately
because you bring in these freshmen who
are ready to play now and you got a
junior senior and these coaches are
looking at it going hey I got to make a
decision here and it used to be where
you wanted that
junior and senior leadership that's not
the case as much anymore so this is the
four-game transfer rule now so after
four games and you're locked in it's
staying but do you think this is a good
rule it's a good rule then because you
know that before this year if you played
one down yeah any game you lost that
year and so it's really a good rule for
players it's a good rule for coaches
it's just new and so nobody knew exactly
how it was gonna play out in certain
situations this is a very high-profile
case but I think I think at the end of
the day and ultimately it's a really
good rule for players and coaches but
Dabo Sweeney could have strung Kelly
Brian along I I don't know if you talked
to Dabo yet but I'm curious no but I'm
curious if like did he do the right
thing for this for his kid but not for
his team I think he did both I really do
I think that you know dabble is such a
he is so proud of the culture they built
at Clemson and he is you know it's a
family atmosphere and it's not hokey
emits it's for real Mis legitimate and I
think he did what he felt he had to do
in the best interest of one of his
players who he cares deeply for and
Kelly Brian I think he made the right
decision for his team by naming Trevor
Lawrence the the starting quarterback
because he ultimately gives them the
best chance to win a championship so I
think he did what was best in both cases
now the problem is you know if Trevor
Lawrence goes out there Saturday and
gets knocked out of the game he doesn't
get to go back to Kelly Bryant and and
you know in the game last year up in the
Carrier Dome that's exactly what
happened
Kelly Bryant got knocked out of the game
and that was a big part of why Syracuse
was able to pull the upset last year up
in Syracuse why do you think Saban's
gotten away with this with his two
quarterbacks even though we know tua is
who starter and Jalen Hurd says what 26
and 2 I think in his career there
I think that's a question that only
Jalen Hertz gonna answer I don't think
this was I don't think this was Nick
Saban handling the situation any
differently than the devil or being
deceptive in any way I think this is
more of a case of Jalen Hurd saying hey
I'm going to stick this one out
I'm not going to redshirt and transfer
at the end of this year now here's the
the important distinction between Jalen
Hurd's and Kelly Bryan and and most
people you know you got to just make
sure you understand this Kelly Bryant is
a senior right now and he's graduated
and so he has one year to go play Jalen
Hurd's
is on track to graduate the end of this
season and appear it sure to shut it
down right now after four games he could
have two years to go play so even if he
decides I'm gonna stay as the backup and
if they need me I'm here
and gonna try to win another
championship with Alabama he can still
graduate be a graduate transfer and go
somewhere for one year if he wants to do
that so he's in a little different
situation because he still has that
extra year at the end talking to Todd
Blackledge former college and pro
quarterback ESPN college football
analyst he's got Clemson and Syracuse
marquee matchup Ohio State at your alma
mater Penn State what's this game come
down to Todd last year when they played
and Penn State was in position to win
and led the majority of the game but in
the fourth quarter they could not block
the Ohio State defensive front but that
group took over the game they pressured
trace McSorely they didn't allow say
Quan Barkley to run the football and
that's what the difference in the game
was I think Penn State's offensive lines
has got to show up I think trace
McSorley
is the best most exciting quarterback in
college football he's the best leader to
me in college football I like them
playing at home you know I like Penn
State but but it's going to be critical
that that offensive line plays better
than they did a year ago and it helps it
helps that Nick Bosa who's the best
defensive player in the country is not
going to be suited up and playing for
Ohio State wait wait wait
tres McSorley the most exciting college
quarterback over - I like - a - but I
love watching tres then maybe that's you
know maybe that's the the blue in my
heart
okay great I mean he's been a blast to
watch but over the course of this career
now tres McCoy's been doing the
assistant is going on three years now he
is an exciting guy plays with a chip on
his shoulder
very similar to the way Baker Mayfield
played the last two years at Oklahoma
and yeah I pull for the guy oh I think
he's fun to watch I fell in love with
him the last two years he's not afraid
and not afraid for a big moment either
and won't be you know intimidated by
Ohio State coming up as far as what's
going on in the NFL you played the
position give the audience a sense of
what it was like when you played
quarterback in the NFL of what the
defense could get away with and hitting
the quarterback I'm shocked by some of
the penalties that I'm seeing now
watching case I mean you know I Clay
Matthews isn't the only guy who's losing
his mind right now it's it's crazy I
mean when I played and it was a long
time ago but there yeah there were no
such protections I mean obviously they
were roughing the passer calls and late
hits called but uh nothing compared to
what it seems to be right now
I gotta believe the NFL is going to kind
of back off this a little bit because
it's really handcuffing defensive
players in a lot of ways I understand
not pile-driving the guy or not you know
driving your body weight into a guy on
the ground but some of the things that
are being called right now it just look
like legitimate hit me yeah you might
still be able to play in the end of
Hilton but you see these guys come in
now you see mahomes playing with Kansas
City a Baker Mayfield Josh Allen and the
advancement with these kids coming out
of college even going into college like
when did it change do you think where
all of a sudden you could give them
terminology that you were running in
college and even in college you were
running terminology or sets that you're
running in the NFL because they are
more advanced than they used to be
absolutely I mean I can remember you
know I was a senior at Penn State we
were still running i-formation football
I mean we we would go play-action on
third down still you know so offenses it
change dramatically and you know and the
kids today you're right it starts even
before they come out of college but it
starts with some of the the Nike in the
elite 11th camps the quarterback camps
that these kids go to the personal
trainer quarterback gurus that some of
these kids go to when they're in high
school and and even before that and then
you know college programs the passing
games are more sophisticated they spend
more time that the teaching the
technology of kids being able to have
you know film on their iPads that they
can watch in their dorm rooms and so all
the preparation everything is just much
more advanced in that and I think that's
why you're seeing guys come into the
league much more ready to play at that
at that kind of a level you know and
Patrick mahomes which I'm thrilled for
Kansas City and and for the success that
he's having I think a lot of people
thought well you know he's from Texas
Tech one of those system quarterbacks we
watched him even in college he was not a
system quarterback he had special you
know kind of unique arm Talent and then
his mental acumen and his understanding
of the passing game and of offenses is
really pretty pretty amazing who is the
father of the new offenses can we go
back to Mike Leach or is it somebody
even before that with June Jones can you
think of this because those guys were
running shoot guys you know Mike Leach
and how mummy were kind of the you know
the the authors of the air raid kind of
stuff and so that coaching tree has
branched off in a lot of different
directions and some people have taken
things with that and and tweaked it a
little bit I think you know one of the
hottest names out there right now is
Lincoln Riley who kind of comes from
that tree he's at Oklahoma and as you
know I think there's a lot of NFL people
that are really intrigued by Lincoln
Riley
spending time in Norman Oklahoma in the
offseason just kind of pick his brain as
a play caller and some of the things
they're doing you know from an offensive
standpoint so I think a lot of it goes
back to how mummy and and and and Mike
Leach you know as far as some of the air
raid and some of that past first
offensive type stuff but you have the
NFL learning from college which I always
found interesting you know Belichick had
been doing that for years where he'd go
visit certain colleges because he wanted
to kind of figure out what they were
doing and that always surprised me that
it was college had the innovators not
the NFL well I think it goes both ways
you know I think college coaches have
always gone to visit with NFL people and
because you know with with NFL coaches I
mean it's it's all about ball you know I
mean it's 24 hours a football they don't
have recruiting they don't have
restrictions of hours that they can meet
with kids and so so that's always
happened where college coaches go and
visit Pro coach and I think why you're
seeing the opposite happening now is you
know in the NFL for the most part
everybody kind of does the same type of
thing so the innovation comes from what
some of the college teams are doing with
dual threat quarterback and some of the
zone read stuff and now some of the RPO
things the run-pass option you know
became really really popular last year
with the Eagles winning the Super Bowl
because they were using a lot of those
things so so there's a little bit of
going back and forth right now between
college and pro but but I think it's
it's always been the case where college
coaches go to visit pro coaches it's
just in the last few years you see more
of the of the office of impact what
happens if Syracuse beats Clemson well I
think you have to tip your hat to Dino
Babers because that would mean Syracuse
is five and OH first of all and they
become a legitimate threat in the ACC
and a chance to win that conference it
also throws you know throws another
crazy wacky thing into the mix and
college football it's gonna take a
monumental effort for Syracuse I do
think that they're playing better
but this will be a very highly motivated
Clemson team playing at home against the
only team that beat him in the regular
season last year you know last year and
I went back and watched that film
Syracuse was able to do some things
offensively against Clinton because
their their of their tempo they use some
formation things that confused
Clemson I don't I don't see that B I
don't see them being able to trick them
as much this year I think that Brent
Venables will have that outstanding
Clemson defense a little bit more locked
in and ready to go so it's gonna take a
monumental effort for for Syracuse to
pull the upset this year
Syracuse should have Kelly Bryant on
their sidelines full uniform signing
already and just put him in uniform you
can't play but just have him over there
on the Syracuse sideline that would a
little try yeah he's good when he's
healthy
ya know when he can stay upright in the
game he's very talented and you know he
played exceptionally well against
Clemson last year so so he gives them a
chance that's for sure
good to busy with you Todd Congrats on
the contract extension have fun with the
Clemson Syracuse game Todd Blackledge
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]